so I leave Nina alone for two seconds to
go pick up the food and what did you do
to my coffee okay we got to eat we got
to get out of here gezina spending way
too much money are you blaming me is
that what's happening it's my fault yes
life Nina life with me it is finally a
warm weekend here in Toronto which means
we can spend the day on the Vespa and
get out and have some fun I've taken the
recipe out a number of times are writing
but just short distances where Nina is
really what's the word vena sensitive to
the cold so it's finally why we have to
go out it's a happy weekend it's sunny
you know stepping pretty doing to put my
shoes on you're supposed to undo the
laces you know I'm supposed to undo the
laces it's a Saturday you ready to go
yeah all decked out ready to go Nina you
ready first ride you would like crazy
excited no why not you're writing it
it's a together thing okay it's husband
and wife cuz we're in love okay show
them love this is all all right good
times
first off Tim Hortons traditional
weekend breakfast for us news excited
Nina's checking their Instagram hey
Rishi what's the same where are we going
where are you going I'm going to spend
time with a happy it's a good thing to
do that's a good thing to do
Nina's hungry these are the donuts yeah
Oh a special case take it bite Nina
I like that elected this is how ripping
but this is like a marshmallow there's a
rat face like marshmallow no it's
whipped cream whenever language
well just tell yourself it's marshmallow
then you'll like it I asked Nina where
do you want to sit she says it doesn't
matter so I want to sit there at the
bench and then she's like no no no you
can't sit there at the bench we gotta
sit here life Nina life with me so I'll
evening alone for two seconds to go pick
up the food
and what did you do to my coffee that's
how it is that's how it came out with
this huge mess you
I thought this picture calling for food
tubers so I took a picture
but and I want to respond to your
comments
with it with a picture by kendall
response
the comment with the pink
message I will record a message to Rishi
Rishi have a great weekend we're
thinking about you a lot as you can
obviously see and Nina is busy messaging
you so have a good weekend Rishi and
everybody watching so just got stopped
by a fan so I can shoot man you haven't
I want your stuff like it's great he
won't say hi and then he said at the end
and stop giving your wife of our time
I told miss each other around man I'm
the one get the hard time how you
feeling I get hungry again you're hungry
holy cow so full how are you hungry i
think that's the main thing that were
too long oh my god I'm so full you're
crazy after that crazy breakfast holy
cow where's the food go look at those
clouds that doesn't look like scooter
friendly weather friends it is supposed
to rain but not until like five o'clock
let's check the weather seven o'clock
yeah i see so we have time we got time
we've tied we totally have time okay
back on the Vespa we're we're going in
and surprise
so Nina and I have a wedding to go to
tomorrow and Nina needs a dress for the
wedding she can't wear white she can't
wear red because it's Chinese
Chinese read the bride has to wear red
right educate where black is funeral so
that's a challenge
that's a challenge so we are here the
Yonge and Dundas in Toronto I'm going to
go check out the eaton centre and co we
can find for Nina hopefully she she
stays on track and only looks for
dressed as I get distracted by other
shattering so here we are
what are you looking at their suits ha i
thought we're here for a dress
I just last night to mendo Chino
you
booze
yes
it's different i like it back to the
original one I like it that's look good
you look you look really happy because
it's hard to find out of 10 okay look at
it you should get it go fine what about
the dress I do a makeup no makeup yeah
let's go look for some if you really
wear a belt with that though because it
has its stomach Christ maybe the
necklace
ok or bracelet
and they maybe if you had a gold like
wrist thing
well but you can get one like
like this I like it it's good so we
happy am I gonna have to carry it's
gonna carry anyhow oh you can carriers
thanks man I'm the family donkey I get
the character name is going into
express men
and just coming back out and now Nina's
going into express he now has a lot of
stuff to try on i immediately i gave her
most of that stuff you got a lot of
stuff there Nina I can't in change room
with Nyna because there are no benches
outside express for a moment so wow you
know I think I'm gonna have to stop
recording right about now yeah yeah
maybe when she tries it on I'll turn the
cam Ron we'll see alright this is a
husband kick all right another husband's
dick oh yeah that's a winner this is
another Evan pic I got to be honest
husband is picking some good clothes for
the way what do you think wife you can
show the wife right now she's changing
but hope she's trying on another husband
pic there it is love made me do it well
just okay man I'm saying no to that one
jeans are next okay I did pick the jeans
you are only supposed to buy a dress I
know look at how much stuff do you have
here oh we can I know I picked them okay
except the orange one I hear I picked
everything else so it's on me she's are
you blaming me is that what's happening
it's my fault yes the credit card is
bouncing up today maybe we should take
Nina home before it things that we need
we have to put all this on the vest by
two by the way she won
husband the family donkey gets to carry
more clothes we need to look at the
men's stuff I don't need stuff man i'm
rocking i'm rocking to believe we're
befall I mean believe we're in the house
where's your believe we're Fran at home
that's not cool we ever get out of here
colinas spending way too much money
all right we're here we've never been
here before it's the basil box what do
you think
different a what did you get
with the lemongrass chicken I look at
that that's cool
and there's the wife also yummy he's
going to try name is gonna try this
place just opened up so stay healthy
what is it good
all right nice Nick voted against mr.
awesome and welcome what do you do what
do you do I do yeah mark the route back
she cool man love it yeah
I really appreciate what to do thanks so
much
awesome and have a great day okay I'm
done Nina's done I'm so full right now
the stomach disbursed him it was good
nice relatively healthy stuff I know
you're hot but are you full
Oh temperature Tracy what
pretty quality up there yourself a
little bit more time I think you know
had me do some illegal jaywalking
they're actually work against illegal
friend I mean I jaywalk all the time any
but I don't always believe in the rules
Nina is more of a traditional
no breaker I feel like it's starting to
rain yeah it is I had to announce plan
but maybe we should go exciting news I
got a message from Chris yella boy
three-time New York bestseller writes a
whole bunch of books the guy who's been
to every country in the world I think he
hit it before he was 30 I supposed to
meet up with him in New York last minute
Ryan Holloway was gonna introduce me to
him and I said that I'm in tirana when
he said hey I'm coming to toronto on
monday you want to meet up and do
something so that'd be pretty cool we'll
see hopefully that gets unattended we
can make it work we're back here rest of
the time what is this motorcycle think
he is parking accident me huh I mean
people are walking by definitely
checking out the Vespa the challenge is
scene of all of Nina's stuff will fit in
our trunk combined with her huge water
bottle
pack it in there yep look at that easy
good job baby we made it back just in
time it's a good thing we didn't go to
the other place I want it you can see
the rain already coming down on my
helmets there need to go to the bank and
I think it's starbucks happy hour
two-for-one Frappuccino so we're
probably check that out but first we got
to get inside and get out of the rain
what are you doing in our front walkway
Nina what are we growing cherry tomatoes
cucumbers peppers all right we relax for
a bit there relax for a bit lay down did
you press their end up in nice thing you
know chillin Saturday afternoon we're
gonna go to the benefit either quickly
yeah and then we're going to go see if
we can catch a ticket to what's a call
no no civil war civil war captain
america we'll see we're gonna try and go
to York that long which is you crazy
packed [ __ ] you go alright Japanese off
I'm at Yorkdale mall this is the second
mom we've been to today and the two kind
of iconic malls in Toronto and I
actually got really lucky because
parking here is crazy the doing
renovations and expanding and so there's
more cars than spots always let's just
thing but I was just happening to come
through an aisle and I was following a
couple and they just happen to pull out
like yes so Nina's inside getting
tickets hopefully hopefully it's not
sold out and we'll go watch movie
okay it was super busy for our time
would have to stay like right at the
front put our internet so
we have a 10-14 showing and whatever
630 there for hours
we're going to
gonna walk home
I love this will go hang on the chapters
go check out some books
I love escalators
are almost same fight
and then I can also pull a Nina stomach
then she makes crazy noises like that
not chapters anymore just called indigo
what are you reading with you pick up
food to grow and jamie's 15 minute meals
all right maybe I can do something 15
minutes yeah wait did I just sign myself
up for making meals in 15 minutes I
don't think I did no no I can't do it
totally can't do you know got a caramel
macchiato how was it and I got a waffle
cone caramel Frappuccino I gotta find
some books you're gonna sit here and
read your mind some folks in vacuum so
I'm developing a leadership development
course or not really a course a program
for the people in my business who are
leaders who I want them to get better
who want them to push through limiting
personal beliefs and this may evolve
into a video series maybe a new book who
knows some super passionate excited
about it right now so I'm learning
learning learning trying to get as much
of the knowledge out there on the topics
I'm gonna be checking out these to the
power of habit and triggers I talk a lot
about the environment and how the
environment matters environment that
you're in you and good things if you
have like greatness I'm still constantly
kind of evolving and learning myself how
to make me remember how to make your
habits better and how to influence
others to make habit stick for them and
make them make changes their environment
so I've already research to learn a lot
but gonna check out these two books and
see if I yell or anything new at the
public hammer again to show how cute my
wife is in her glasses Nina's very
serious don't mess with Nina and her
food books
serious business Nina is very excited
about something this guy
he said he went to visit this Greek
family and then you don't let the way
spoon so every time when they finish
fish they buried the fifth note they put
the fish bone in the soil so that the
rec room come to get the plan relax pray
they go this animal my pack so maybe
and copied to the ground coffee it
remember warm the leaves are love the
things that excite my wife it is very
special excited it's very much i love
thing you get excited see these things i
am 0 interesting but maquina happy so
it's good what time is it great ok well
so we're gonna go home I'm going to buy
one of those two books and not the other
one I forget what the title was but I
emailed myself I also use the time to
read ink magazine which is cool and
started looking for i'm looking at
putting on a mindfulness class at
toronto dance salsa would you take a
mindfulness class what's mine
mindfulness is like thinking about the
present moment and not being too
stressed out being grateful whatever
mean we'll take it for me she might
start sleeping or might walk out but
anyway i'm looking at potentially
putting on like a weekend morning
mindfulness class kinda funny oh yeah
I'd like you start your day with it or
maybe weekday morning to I don't know
and then I started looking at snapchat
too and I thought hmm maybe when I'm not
vlogging I'll do with snapchat what do
you guys think should i snapchat on days
when I'm not vlogging I'm thinking about
it let me know you can find me Evan
Carmichael on snapchat leave a comment
let me know if you think I should be
doing it I like your I like your look at
Nina look how cheese cheese of her
screening cut raining it's not raining
there's no rain is zero rain but you're
still cute okay we're gonna go home
relax a bit and then come back to the
movie
we are back at yorkdale it is actually
raining this time Nina deserves to have
the hoodie a good job I should go to yep
two ready to watch so the war are we
getting something to eat there what do
you think
I don't know I feel like I might get
sick if I do but I feel like I want
something to snack on to don't get
popcorn because I'm kind of feeling
popular know what I want to be sick
tomorrow either we'll see okay we'll see
we'll see we'll see we'll see I told
mean I'm thinking about getting one of
those poutines and then she goes oh I'm
hungry now I want a poutine that looks
good we're gonna get our own routine
okay you do classic and I'll do bacon
sounds like a plan what's up man we got
a fan of the channel this pump it up
what's your name bro Dennis Dennis what
do you do man don't work you work your
hustle you're gonna start a business
real soon soon man I'm excited what's
your favorite video in the channel damn
it rough diamond dodge diamond dash
that's an early one this is michael nice
man the nelson mandela nice tyra banks
nice
what's up we can't video tape all right
that's the end so it wouldn't let me
film inside them and even inside the
theater just in anyway let's get moving
we enjoy so it is now one
ish in the morning we're going to go
home oh it's cold we're gonna sleep
we're going to get up tomorrow some fun
what are you doing tomorrow we got to
clean up we gotta we didn't get to the
bank way out of the bank we got to do
some salsa getting into a wedding love
the fun stuff so thank you guys for
joining us on our day today hope you're
having a great weekend continue to
believe and see you soon i will see you
soon ok i know it sufficiently past the
blog date and we already said goodbye
earn everything but Nina is wearing her
outfit and I wanted to show her off what
we got this is the final look getting
ready for the white I'm gonna change
this isn't going to be what I wear yeah
but Nina's stained like this for the
class as we go teach salsa and then go
to what we got ready then did it end did
it down Evan approves let's go dance